[Musik]
vielen dank auch heute wollen wir uns
noch mal die militärische lage in der
ukraine ansehen dabei zwei verschiedene
orte einmal du hast gesagt mario pohl
erstmal auf der einordnung wieder auf
der karte haben wir hier oben die
hauptstadt wo es weiterhin auch täglich
raketenangriff gibt mario pohl hier
unten im südosten des landes wir sehen
alles außen herum schon rot man könnte
also denken das ganze gebiet ist erobert
aber nein mario pohl hält seit fast zwei
wochen der belagerung stand und dort
gibt es weiter heftige kämpfe als erstes
möchte ich kurz zeigen gestern gab es
eine waffenruhe eine zumindest 2
stündige waffenruhe in der einige
menschen es geschafft haben aus ihren
häusern zu kommen und auch über die
sogenannten humanitären korridore die
stadt zu verlassen was die menschen dort
gesehen haben nachdem sie mehr als eine
woche in ihren kellern verbracht haben
war einfach unfassbar ich möchte das
einfach mal
hier zeigen hier sind die menschen die
rauskommen ich werde gleich noch mal
anhalten man sieht jedes haus brennt
wirklich jedes haus ist anbrennen wir
haben hier nochmal ein panorama der
stadt wo man auch sieht dass das
wirklich überall herrschen also liegt
stadt ist wirklich in flammen und
der ja der zeitpunkt so zu sagen war er
nicht gewählt das war nicht dass
irgendwann die angezündet hat sondern es
war eher zufällig waren sie raus
gekommen sind und wir zeigen es einfach
noch einmal jedes haus man sieht dass
hier da ist eines dieser schauen wir mal
weiter jedes haus brennt hier sind die
menschen kaum zu glauben mit ihren
trolleys ja also einfach menschen die
aus ihren kellern herauskommen mit einer
einkaufstüte in der einen hand mit einem
trolley in der anderen hand die
versuchen diese hölle von mario pohl zu
verlassen wo sie hingehen wissen wir
nicht genau auch vor ihnen man sieht
dass brennende häuser insofern alles ja
unglaublich dass so was im jahr 2022 in
europa passiert dort ist es angesprochen
wie er kämpft dort eigentlich mario wir
wissen auf der einen seite ist es die
ukrainische sind ukrainische
marineinfanteristen und die
nationalgarde regiment azoff ist das
ganz genau diese stadt halten auf der
anderen seite sind es teilweise die
sogenannten kämpfer der volksrepublik
netz teilweise auch russischer soldaten
aber und das ist ganz wichtig viele von
denen sind auch aus dem kaukasus dort
hingereist hier sehen wir von herrn
kadyrow von ramzan kadyrov dem
tschetschenen führer selbst gepostet
eine tschetschenische spezialeinheit die
also hier in mario pohl kämpft im
hintergrund man sieht auch dass mehr
ganz spannend
und hier sehen wir ebenfalls truppen aus
dem kaukasus und zwar aus dagestan das
ist die nachbarrepublik von
tschetschenien die für einen freudentanz
auf in der in der tradition der
islamischen tradition ihrer ihrer
heimatregion und
schauen uns das einfach noch mal an um
das ganze noch ein bisschen einzuordnen
als auch hier zu sehen häuserkampf die
kämpfen vor ort mit panzerfäusten die
sie gleich wegschmeißen diese abfeuern
jetzt mit die gruppe abgefeuert müssen
wir das jetzt ein gewehr
der hat eine panzerfaust und so weit
dass eine panzerfaust abgeschossen wir
sehen also da es gibt wirklich haus um
haus weiter gekämpft parallel zu dem
schweren beschuss und hier was ich ganz
spannend finde ist dass wir hier diese
diese weste sehen die der mann hat auf
der nämlich zu sehen
london eine spezialeinheit des
russischen innenministeriums
bekannt sozusagen als prügel einheit im
land die immer dann rein geht wenn die
polizei nicht mehr klarkommt die aber in
dem fall jetzt auch militärische
aufgaben übernimmt
soviel zur lage in mario pohl und
versuchen noch einmal weiter zu gehen
und zwar wieder auf die strategie der
ukraine und zu konzentrieren die
ukrainer wieso halten die zu einer
riesigen übermacht überhaupt noch stand
wie dieser russischen armee die wir
sehen überall überall sind ihre
fahrzeuge überall panzer überall
schützenpanzer lkw und so weiter ein
interessantes video hat uns erreicht von
einer organischen einheit
das zeigt ich glaube dass man ganz kurz
hier vorne einen russischen konvoi der
fährt also sozusagen von hier links nach
rechts fährt hier weiter und gleich
sehen wir eine explosion die dort
stattfindet und diese explosion weil wir
gucken uns das einmal an hat sehr eigene
charakteristik und zwar jetzt passiert
sie jobs was hier eingesetzt wurde ist
nicht etwa eine panzerfaust ist nicht
etwa ein panzer oder so etwas sondern es
ist eine spreng schlauch ein schlauch
den man irgendwo in ein gebiet rhein
einschließt oder liegt das vermint ist
und dann springt man diesen schlauch und
hofft dass alle explodieren die ukraine
hätten diesen spreng strauch hier an man
glaubt es kaum gegen einen russischen
konvoi
lassen einmal abspielen man sieht diese
länge entlang der straße wird also gibt
es über viele kilometer gibt es eine
große explosion immer wieder kleine
explosion wenn man genau guckt es
innerhalb 30 40 explosion sie finden
dort statt parallel zu dem konvoi also
klassische partisanen taktik wo geht die
klassische geriet taktik der ukraine die
alles nimmt was sie findet um ebendiese
russischen konvois zu sprengen und wir
sehen jetzt einmal noch wie es danach
aussieht die aufnahmen sind von gestern
abend hier sehen wir dieser konvoi oder
ein konto auch in der gleichen region
vergleichen einheit angegriffen hier
vorne ein sogenanntes btr 80 also ein
russisches ein schützenpanzer da hinten
brennt ein weiteres fahrzeug das ist es
wie dieser wie dieser konvoi sozusagen
danach aussah und wie gehen am ende noch
einmal auf die auf die karte um uns das
anzusehen denn mit dieser taktik hat die
ukraine gerade rundum knifflig im süden
so sehr da gab es wirklich sehr schnell
viele geländegewinne der russen aber
gerade rundum kiew hat die ukraine die
sich sehr erfolgreich angewandt und ist
dort tatsächlich mit fußsoldaten also
wirklich schon mit kleinen gruppen von
20 30 soldaten zu fuß unterwegs durch
die wälder lauert dort den russischen
kommen wo es auf und hat allein gestern
sowohl westlich vom kfd
normaltarif als auch nördlich von kiew
den ort mich schon zurückerobert und
damit sozusagen kiew etwas entlastet und
die russen etwas zurückgedrängt insofern
die ukrainer hier mit einer sehr
erfolgreichen taktik woanders im
häuserkampf kann man die natürlich
weniger gut anwenden
[Musik]